hey guys Ryan is right here and I am
Jerry the weddi today we are going to
watch marbles vases barb we're much
Marvel space wanting to a look back
something awesome that was released at
comic-con
that a [ __ ] ton of people are requesting
this is like a highlights reel I don't
know it's like the equivalent to like
Marvel doing a clip show this is just us
going oh yeah remember that [ __ ] I saw
that movie but in its entirety yeah so
good knows a good moment and there's
good moment they played there
yeah Marvel is awesome so it's like this
is like now that's what I call Marvel
vol 2 a Marvel is already God and now
God wants to remind us who God really is
they don't need to do this whatever
we're about to watch yeah I feel like
unless it's unless it's different than
what I thought it was but like like it's
usually DC we need to do do we need to
look back on phase 1 into it seems like
we've all pretty much been here yeah we
all know what's going on your movies
make like a billion dollars like me I
think we were caught up Marvel is like
the one studio for whose movies like
every time they released a movie you
have to go back and study yes like they
should have done somebody this for the
x-men movies that would be cool I did
something like that actually what am I
talking about
the x-men trailers in timeline order
yeah you did that was clever wasn't it
yeah
stop monetize but it has like 300,000
views to be able to make curse me curse
god damn it that's the ultimate like
monkey's butt ha curse is like oh look
at all these views we can't capitalize
on what are we doing we're breaking the
fourth wall again we're not supposed to
talk about possible income earnings of
youtube the Domus knows about that the
turkeys a little dry what are we
watching Marvel's greatest hits real
that's right I just expect Stan Lee to
be sitting in like a high-back satin
chair look how [ __ ] rich I am
oh I'm Stan Lee I'm Stanley we've been
getting so much fan mail and here in the
Marvel Studios we decided to do a clip
show remember this amazing time that
Ironman met
okay okay well we'll get around to this
let's do this five minutes of marble
awesome happen yeah actually really cool
let's see it though it shouldn't be one
I'm not sure with cherries
[Music]
I will protect as garden overwhelmed and
nothing but a boy trying to prove
himself feeling such an ass pretty
awesome actually
well yeah you're gonna wanna give up
doing this all day
[Music]
I cannot help you if you're gonna start
all this again there is nothing except
this I just finally know what I have to
do
[Music]
these people are infected taking their
lives will gain you nothing
so take mine
[Music]
what may teeth so special nothing wasn't
a bad well I'm just a kid from Brooklyn
[Music]
you're the only superhero in the world
you become Oh Oh Gary just we don't have
to talk they give my ball no attention
yeah marks that's our one like problem
see if they could work together to fight
the battles that we never could
[Music]
[ __ ] really good there is no stopping
it there is only this is monsters and
magic and nothing we were ever trained
for you were made to be rules how
desperate are you you call on such lost
creatures to defend you there is no
version of this where you come out on
top I have an army we have a Hulk New
York
start something pure something exciting
then come the mistakes the compromises
people sacrifice it changes you
I'd rather be a good man than a great
king
the price of freedom is high and it's a
price I'm willing to pay you can take
away my house all my tricks and toys but
I am Iron Man
yes the world is a vulnerable place and
yes we help make it that way
you need us
you know why do enlighten us because
we're also the ones best qualified to
defend it yeah [ __ ] love the
adventures
yeah like remember those aliens
destroyed
yeah let's see how well you did you
survive against humans they are not
cowering wretches we were promised to
challenge them is to court death I don't
think you understand what you've started
letting the Avengers loose on this world
they're dangerous
they surely are and the whole world
knows it
every world knows what the hell's that
got to do with anything the stench of 12
billion people is in the hands of these
criminals I come from the planet outlaws
Billy the Kid Bonilla fine
sounds like a place which I would like
to visit it's not the world's our spies
anymore not even a world of Heroes
the age miracles
they've gone their separate ways
you'll come back
you'll need them - oh yeah
I'm surely happy
rocking the stick babe stowaways in your
blood is that from Avengers 2 no that
was from a from an audience Alex oh yeah
where they go to visit or where the
Ronin talks to Thanos that was pretty
cool who's actually pretty awesome moves
for the greatest it seemed like the
connections they were making a lot well
yeah and then it can be kind of tiring
to go back through the Marvel stuff and
to think about it but that's in that
sort of bite-size way it's like oh yeah
like it yeah enjoy all that stuff like
you know like if you weren't able to
catch up like remind yourself of all the
movies like from cuz there's a lot of
[ __ ] movie - keep watching this will
be like yeah ok let's go watch Avengers
2 now you know yeah it's like it's a
perfect bite sized forum where you like
oh that stuff is really cool isn't it
like yeah and the Avengers is one of my
all-time favorite movies hands-down
definitely in the top five I would say
top 5 favorite movies it's like have you
seen The Avengers that is a pretty
killer it was also about the Avengers
was they made all of their powers even
cooler than their solo films well
because they really knew how to use them
yeah actively and give everybody a
distinct role in the team Joss Whedon
brilliant [ __ ] man jaws with you know
yeah I'm sorry is that Konami yeah I
know I do
yeah fellatio that's what I'm referring
to
oh yeah if you guys are new to the
channel you can subscribe to the rejects
though shoutouts totally forgot about
the shout outs veronica six-toes dick
that's who you think is Ryan right rocks
my socks where's my shoutout a home dog
home dog deity okay Veronica Veronica
rocks my socks Veronica rocks my [ __ ]
who did not see that coming haha see um
guy Oh
coming coming CMMI
Veronica makes me come yeah Master
General long we were really excited when
she sees oh she'll be really excited she
wanted to shout out she knows what this
territory is if you're a girl wanting a
shout out to get ready for me to talk
about things like this
intercourse you know sexual intercourse
hi Veronica do people use intercourse in
any other way any other context I have
to look up the the definition to see if
there's any flexibility there yeah
because people go intercourse and it's
like why specify sexual intercourse
yeah it's like if there's if you have to
say sexual intercourse then it implies
at least that intercourse because
intercourse is also just like you know
it's like inside course it's like you
could use that well that's what I've
been while I was asking you people use
it for other contexts I imagine you
could I'm sure because intercourse just
the parts that make up that word are
vague enough they don't simply imply a
sex it's just because of the cultural
thing okay so problem I guess is
probably you could use it in a different
content okay well Veronica um I want to
have intercourse with you that's what it
comes down to at the end of the day
despite whatever society says I want to
have intercourse with you we should do
this I have a box of condoms hasn't been
used in three years maybe you should get
a new box of cantos no Manish it cost
money so do children that's great epic
Lama can you guys give me a shout out
and do the Deadpool test footage ooh be
epic and you guys are great the Deadpool
test footage is up my friend yeah we are
great we're beyond great actually yeah
we are epic llama that's what we are
Oh whit look do you think you are we are
epic llama
we are the epic all of us are a part of
the epic llama oh that's a better way to
look at it yes yeah rather than a
competition or a community yeah there's
a little epic llama in all
there is a little bit of epic llama
penis come get some ham oh dude
Jerry gum give me a [ __ ] try playing
off you did know what you were doing
sorry
that's from Napoleon Dynamite okay jail
on host ah Anna I imagine this is a
German named John huh stop no it's shout
out please recently subscribed thanks
and keep up the great work
um yeah dude you could totally get a
shout out as a girly thing as girl be
good bigger tits mmm
you could have tits my friend Ron can
play with in titties you don't burn
Monica together man watch YouTube play
with each other for a while I imagine
all female subscribers will bow down to
my authority if this is a dude this is
gonna be awesome for ya dude if your
dude okay I'll watch you have sex with
Veronica no this is a very personal
episode yeah if you're a if you're a guy
I'm okay with that
let's see your penis send me a picture
first I must have crew did you solicit a
dick pic because you'll probably get one
that's the thing is like this is the
Internet he'd better I'm gonna be upset
if you don't send me your date when I
tried doing a threesome on Craigslist I
made sure to see the dick dude you could
do dick reactions you like solicit dick
pic we should do to take reactions you
could review dick pics and give like
helpful tips
I should have someone like you look up
like a bunch of weird dicks come over
here and then they show me it one at a
time and then the audience can't see the
dick well guys um so this is YouTube so
we're gonna ask a question at the end of
the video right interaction here you
know getting personal with the fans here
I'm drinking on camera it makes it look
like you know it's casual we're just
hanging out naturally real people you
probably need to have food and beverage
in your life to subsist what if like
off-camera we were like this really
serious business
yeah we're just like crawling facade
we're not into anything or very serious
we're fat ears with British accents we
probably would be to know we'd be
Australian de Mon I'm rollin raw cocoa
yah go done
anyway I brought all this up so I can
ask you a question since we did a video
about Marvel how about this do you shave
your pubic hair or do you not shave your
pubic hair if so how do you uh if you do
shave it is it like completely bald do
you make like a shape with it is a
little bit you know or do you just let
the whole [ __ ] Bush come out you know
like this Jesus Christ room yeah yeah
and that's just vagina talk you know
guys can be creative too I want to try
carving a Laura into my pubic that
sounds difficult but just it was very
difficult I was very young and you see
like it would need a lot of precision to
get that done oh yeah I need a
incredibly tiny razor yeah you do not
think this through [ __ ] up our video